you've got pregnant while you're on this
movie is that yeah you did took my
husband to a bachelorette party which by
the way don't do that ladies because
it's it sounds cool the guy to hold your
purse that's not gonna like roofie you
but he got he knocked me up wait at a
bachelorette party
yeah we're worried like he's very close
with my girlfriends and we were in Vegas
and we went to go see the Chippendales
concert which I also highly recommend
and I was super nervous about going to
see the show I was very intimidated but
then I get in there and it's like the
wife beaters are coming off and like ah
and I got and then we were staying in
like the Sly Stallone suite at the
Planet Hollywood
yeah and they apparently got my husband
really excited and you know the birds
and the bees wait a minute you know that
your child was conceived in that's why
Stallone
in my mind yeah and they named it he's a
close personal friend to all of us why
is that a turn-on for your husband was
probably most attractive with that I had
had like six vodkas and I was super in a
good spot or watching the Chippendales
you know he was like yeah that's my wife
he saw an opportunity and she was on a
set with child I was old school I've
been to that semester know sweetie yeah
I know me I got somebody because I'm old
school out pull out I don't know how any
of this is promoting a movie
you